foreign
foreign
thank you
um
I have with me David packman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David packman show and I wanted to talk
to David Pacman he is
[Music]
[Music]
gave it Pac-Man he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic and that's a beta male
they go along with homosexuality hold on
Buddy we gotta look that's a lot that's
a lot we would everything that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman a beta male dog but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of David Pac-Man
[Music]
he is
[Music]
David Patman is
[Music]
David Patman is
[Music]
you're not here to communicate I really
appreciate you coming on I'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you we're not communicating you're
acting like that because you're asking
bizarre questions like an idiot and you
wasting my time goodbye
[Music]
let him know
[Music]
that's a progression folk all men who
are progressive
[Music]
look at that look at that look at that
look at that look at that look at that
look at that
look at that look at that that is
smarter than you what who thinks he's
smarter than you what you think you're
smarter than you know
at that look at that Pac-Man's a loser
Pac-Man's a loser Pac-Man's a loser at
ant-man's a loser
like that look at that Alex Jones is
lying to you that might come as a shop
[Music]
Jones has fake callers Jones has fake
callers Jones has fake callers Jones has
fake color
this is
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilet but shakes
[Music]
were looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump and
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive dumps
[Music]
10 times
[Music]
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
the price
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
well welcome everybody it is great to be
back in the studio let's first go to
Mike pillow because he's giving an
interview right now at the Trump rally
and then we will discuss but the Frank
speech app that helps me get the word on
communicate over there we're all working
together in the media and that's and by
the way apple and them approved it right
away that was weird and know I'm going
what I'm sure there is a sync issue it
appears to be on their end yeah
it fixes it
[Music]
there in Selma North Carolina that's
prillo as we know him and he has a big
proposal big big proposal we're doing a
class action
all machine
here he is now getting pulled into
another interview it looks like good we
got to get where to get rid of that woke
trash in the public schools it's
ridiculous yes and I've spoken
not every school board meeting since
late April of last year and so totally
normal day in Selma North Carolina the
site of today's Trump rally it is so
great to see everybody I am back from
Las Vegas I do have some stories to
share from really from my flight uh back
I this is not a joke folks this this is
when I say this I'm not kidding not a
joke I was sitting next to one of Alex
Jones's lawyers
on the flight and uh just one of one of
and not not recent
um and he's like a First Amendment guy
he's like I think he's [ __ ] nuts you
know but excuse me oh my God excuse me
um but uh it was not a joke and
um I'll talk a little bit about that
later also some of the uh
some of the most vile people I've ever
been around on a plane sat right behind
me
and I'll talk about that a little bit a
little bit
but uh we have a rally today the rally
is in Selma North Carolina it is going
to be a complete and total mess complete
and total mess uh that's my prediction
now sometimes when I go oh we're
expecting Trump to be unhinged some
people will write to me and they'll go
David if you really want to be a
journalist you shouldn't say that it's
unhinged until Trump speaks and it's
unhinged
we've done a hundred of these events
it's never not been unhinged and I'm not
a journalist I'm a commentator so I'm
going to take the Liberty if I can of
predicting it will be unhinged even
though it hasn't started yet
okay and you got if if I end up being
wrong
I'll eat a bumper sticker which by the
way we're going to be giving out and
I'll talk about that in a little bit uh
let me say thank you to Jeff's money for
small streams raided Roy Dustin D head
Pats kafka-esque
King oh no that's it and also tool moo
five great people grabbing some twitch
Prime subscriptions to kick us off today
uh and it really is uh it really is
great to be back where do I even want to
start today I have a bunch of different
things I have some games I have uh
oh let's see how news max is cut yeah
everybody we have three streams today
Newsmax will be covering the rally so
we're monitoring that
right side broadcasting will be covering
the route oh they're interviewing
someone let's listen they're evil
foreign
do you know it's possible president
Trump does watch our network if he is
watching right now what do you want to
say to him
we're voting for you in 24 buddy we got
your back
[Music]
[Applause]
you know one of the saddest things and I
don't I don't really feel too sad about
it every day I just think it's sort of a
sad reality is that these people that
are so devoted to Trump they're really
devoted they'll go and wait for hours at
a crowded rally with feted sanicans as
their only access to facilities for
hours and hours and hours
um
for Trump they'll donate money to Trump
they'll do all these things Trump
doesn't give two you know what's about
these people Trump as a rich
New York City guy has spent his life
trying to stay away from these people
and yet they're so committed to him and
he scams them it's it's it it makes you
a little bit sad it makes you a little
bit sad Lin says via a very powerful
first Super Chat David thank you for
everything thank you Lynn David Seeley
says David sir the bangs of bags of
mango back in stock at Whole Foods I
believe that they are I haven't been
fetid Sani cans is actually a good band
name probably like black metal or
something like that yeah it's not a bad
it's not a bad name thanks to rumdog for
the twitch Prime subscription you're
number six today very much appreciate
that and appreciate you let's do just
one voicemail uh Eric from Mass
continues to call in he will not stop I
think he thinks I'm gonna end up in
prison for having said the vaccines uh
uh are safe and work
well you know go after this one go after
that one
be careful what you wish for my friend
because if you remember you were the one
be careful what you wish for my friend
who lied about the vaccine I lard about
the vaccine I lard I olive oil I butter
I all sorts of food lubricants I have
used with the vaccine Eric is exactly
right all the info that I gave you and
sent you over to you left on your
machine you lied about it being approved
FDA you've got can you imagine thinking
the vaccines aren't FDA approved at this
point imagine that able to get it and
take it even after it was deemed a
poison even after the statistics were
out from England even after the
statistics were else in Japan about
Ivermectin the I imagine still believing
the Japan Ivermectin thing now that we
have proper randomized controlled trials
which say that Ivermectin doesn't
nothing nothing for covid so anyway yeah
and you kept doing it so uh if you think
that's funny I guess when they come
knocking on your door they'll rest your
ass you must be gonna be laughing your
[ __ ] ass off okay think the
police are going to show up and they're
going to say excuse me sir you said the
vaccine was safe you're under arrest
maybe that's the dystopian authoritarian
nightmare that these people want us to
live in
but fortunately we don't
fortunately we don't
um David having a watch party in
Brooklyn any favorite food spots in New
York City oh I couldn't yes so many I
couldn't even name them uh having a oh
by the way let me say if anybody is
watching our stream today in any kind of
bar restaurant wherever around the world
after the fact people write me and they
go David we we had the bar at such and
such put on your stream and we were all
watching it send that stuff to me during
the stream to info davidpackman.com
because we'll put it up and do shout
outs to people I know that the the
stream is very popular in bars and
prisons uh prisons is an interesting one
but in bars and prisons it can be very
very popular thank you to Rachel link
for the twitch Prime subscription you're
number seven today welcome Rachel I've
got a couple things for you let's do um
let's do another round of Deepak Chopra
or Jordan Peterson this is a game where
we put a quote up on the screen
and then we guess whether the person who
said it is Deepak Chopra or Jordan
Peterson people are actually pretty good
at this game okay let's start it up here
we go the way that Consciousness appears
to me is that it's a faculty let's say
that confronts possibility we call that
possibility sometimes we call it the
future so I don't see us as driven
deterministically like clocks I see us
instead as agents confronting a
landscape of possibility and that's what
Consciousness does is enable us to shape
that possibility into actuality okay so
let's get a poll going
Chopra or Peterson
Chopra Peterson okay we got that going
on YouTube you can vote
let's get it going on Twitch as well
who said it
Chopra Peterson and let's start there
and then we will look over on YouTube
right now it is 50 50. 50 50 on this one
and on Twitch people leaning heavily
towards Deepak Chopra on this one
on YouTube it is now Jordan Peterson is
pulled slightly ahead interesting who
said it
twitch Chopra is winning we've never
seen a split like this
back to 50 50 on YouTube
Now by a roughly two to one margin the
audience on Twitch believes that it is
Deepak Chopra who said this over on
YouTube it is Deepak Chopra by a very
small margin 51.49
5149 Chopra
uh about 60 40 now on Twitch all right
okay let's just end the polling uh let's
just see who said it
the way
is that it's a faculty let's say that
confronts possibility right we call that
possibility well sometimes possibility
sometimes we call it potential like your
potential sometimes we call it the
future
so I don't see us as driven
deterministically like clocks which is
apparently I think although I've been
accused of misunderstanding Sam Harris
before but I think that's the that's the
argument that he makes I see us instead
as agents confronting a landscape of
possibility
and that what Consciousness does is
enable us to shape that possibility into
actuality pretty deep stuff guys and by
and of course if anyone goes wow that
really doesn't make any sense the Jordan
Peterson acolytes come up and they go
you're misunderstanding or you're not
smart enough to understand what he's
saying so there it is there it is
um all right
we'll just do one round I want to keep
saving these for for the future but we
have a bunch of them and eventually
we'll get back to gnome Chomsky or Bobby
Fischer which is another one that that's
uh surprisingly difficult
a surprisingly difficult yeah Chopra and
Jordan Peterson really are experts at
word salads
uh oh hold on excuse me I've got to
adjust the monitor here hold on
I did a very deep clean today of the
studio and some things did not I do it
very infrequently because things end up
uh you know
out of place and I need everything just
so ladma says wouldn't it be weird if
Trump did the unimaginable and
apologized for his four-year as
president four years as president
instigating the riots and the way he
fumbled covid nah he's too dumb no he's
too narcissistic
Pappy says have you ever thought about
taking your show to CNN or MSNBC now I'm
not interested they're not interested in
me I'm not interested in having a boss
uh I I've got it I've got it pretty good
um okay let's see what else we have here
because there is a lot a lot happening
oh someone sent me this this is kind of
interesting the add Fontes media I don't
know what that is it's they do a media
bias chart but I don't know if ad Fontes
is a person or if ad means advertising
or I have no idea anyway they have a
page about the David packman show bias
and reliability it seems pretty generic
like no one's really even looked into us
but it's kind of funny so bias and
related reliability ratings for the
David packman show bias skus left yeah I
would say so reliability generally
reliable
slash analysis or other issues
I I don't even I don't know what that
means
so then I look down
and it says uh okay reliability we come
in at a 39 and bias at a minus 10.89 now
I what bias negative probably means
biased left and positive probably means
conservative would be my guess
reliability 39
let's see reliability scores for
articles and shows are 0 to 64. above 40
is generally good below 24 is a problem
and 24 to 40 is a range of possibility
with some sources falling there because
they're heavy in opinion and Analysis
well yeah that's that's what we do so
it's weird to have a reliability scale
where if you just do analysis and
opinion it's lower that's weird
listen I don't know what this these
folks say but the young men's Chamber of
Commerce from Wasilla Alaska
uh named this the best show ever
oh that doesn't exist oh hold on no I
mean the um
the the Jewish Rotary Club of
Jacksonville Florida gave me man of the
year
oh that that doesn't exist either oh
well don't worry about that don't worry
it's totally fine nothing nothing to see
here folks
uh okay we're continuing to monitor a
number of different streams in advance
of trump here
who is expected very very soon I want to
say a big thank you to what do we have
here who is our latest twitch Prime
subscriber number eight uh do you guys
or let me see let me see where else I
wanted to go
I do have a lot of different things oh
we have some videos so earlier today
Madison cawthorne spoke at the Trump
rally and it was almost like a
televangelist moment where he seemed to
almost show that God is allowing him to
stand as you guys know Madison
cawthorne's partially paralyzed he's in
a wheelchair and this really rings of
sort of like a um circus tent healer
type thing check this out 7 in dollars a
gallon
my friends this country can change very
quickly yeah and it may seem impossible
people tell me that it's impossible to
change the direction of our country that
it's impossible to root out the
corruption in our government
thank you
well my friends God spared my life he
has given me the strength to stand
before you today
oh man
wow
wow this is um
wow so do not lecture me on what is
impossible
my fellow Patriots Americans are in the
this is this is genuinely sick
what the hell
is anyone else repulsed by this like I
wish he hadn't been in a car accident I
wish he had the use of his legs
but
what is this
what is this
I'm I'm having trouble even
wow it's it's just bad bad
all right so he did that
here's a couple with some conspiracy
shirts
at the event
uh
uh here's two brothers talking to the
media
seem like every meeting I see is
undisgraceful
and we support you guys 100 100 and we
just and we just want to tell the fake
news CNN MSNBC all of y'all
y'all are disgraceful to this country
and we're gonna come after of you
demonic your Devils we get saved are you
guys like
as brothers
if if tomorrow we found out these guys
were just trolling I would be like oh
that makes sense that makes a lot of
sense
right I mean it's if if we found out
this was like a joke that they pulled
we'd be like that makes that makes a lot
more sense than the idea that these
people exist
um
a little kid said he was actually there
to see Joe Biden oh this I have to see
so excited were you when you found out
there was gonna be a rally here
this is excited as hey guys he's the one
that told me about it so
sorry yeah
what are you excited for
I'm the secret body
oh that's genius this kid is a comedic
genius uh I don't know if it so there's
two possible things here right the
parents who bring kids to this trash
they they love to pretend the kids are
really the ones who want to be there and
so it would actually be brilliant if the
kids don't even know what's going on if
they're really just pawns you know and
they're like I guess we're here to see
Biden I don't know
um that's that's great
um if the kids just confuse I mean this
this is unbelievable oh then the parents
say they're there yeah I'm having a hard
time believing the kids were really the
ones who wanted to come to this
um man that is that is genius this kid
is a comedic genius
wow
I think we have to end the stream
because it's hard to imagine there being
any any higher Point than that I mean
that is
these rallies are crazy all right here's
a guy
saying that January 6 was antifa
are we supposed to believe that they
didn't set up the protesters on January
6th right that's I mean that's exactly
right there's video out there that
they're trying to suppress that's all on
people's tick tocks and stuff where they
had antifa members inside the White
House on that day saying we need more
people we need more people I think we're
trying yeah while they were trying to
break through them now why they're why
why was antifa in the white house that's
weird
that's strange
floor in one of these also why would
antifa want to stop Biden from being
inaugurated the lady was in the window
with a megaphone telling people what to
do and where to go yeah there's so many
holes in the official narrative about
yeah here's a guy who says he spent 30
grand going to Trump rallies so far they
cost you guys to drive across the
country I'm just curious like how much
of your own money you know obviously
your own money that you've invested to
do this so this is my 45th Trump rally I
probably invested 30 000 of my own money
coming here it's funny to call it an
investment you know and this is but we
have very low financial literacy in this
country but
hemorrhaging cash to see Trump give the
same speech 45 times is not exactly what
I would call an investment
I might look at index funds bro
I can tell you in the last year it's
it's been worse it's been worse the
flights are double the rental cars are
double gas is almost four dollars a
gallon all along the east coast it's
it's getting ridiculous you know I want
yes yes fair I would look at therapy as
well as index funds good point Nano mom
we want it back to two dollar gas we
want it back to 100 flights and we went
back to cheap rental cars because you
guys right yeah
um okay so that's that we'll get we'll
go to a couple others um
momentarily here but it's
it's pretty bad out there yeah thanks to
Manny and Harry as well as flea girl
and Infamous for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 12. thanks
very much everybody really appreciate
that okay super chat's coming in this is
a parody right like the reporter knows
these people are unhinged or am I
missing something no unfortunately
Jonathan it's all too real
it's all too real and it is absolutely
disgusting absolutely disgusting
um
okay yeah so my i i people are noticing
I'm back I'm back from Vegas yes my
flight yesterday was fine as far as
turbulence goes the flight was on time
uh you know they they had pretzels they
had everything but I sat in front of
some of the most horrible horrible
people I have ever experienced and you
know the funny thing is when I was
waiting in the terminal to get on my
flight
you guys know these moving sidewalks
that a lot of um airports have to get
you more quickly so you got the moving
sidewalk and one of the things you're
supposed to do on the moving set moving
walkway moving walkway sorry one of the
things you're supposed to do on the
moving walkway is
if you want to go that way
you walk on the moving walkway that's
going that way
and I spot a kid uh maybe six years old
and he is walking the opposite direction
and causing chaos people are trying to
get to their flights trying to get
around the kids the people the kid has
no idea what's going on the just walking
the opposite way so I go you know in my
experience
when a kid's doing something like that
you look at the parents I have never met
an annoying kid where the parents
weren't annoying so I look around and I
go where where's the parents
and I see the mom no mask okay no mask
the mask is down here
the mom with no mask
filming
as if it's funny
that Travelers are
you know unable to get around this kid
so I go oh well there's your explanation
it's the parents
uh they were sitting right behind me so
it was actually a family of four two of
them were right behind me and the other
two right behind them and
every single if you can think of all the
things that are sometimes annoying on a
flight
all of them were going on first of all
the kids just straight up took off the
masks when they got on the plane and the
parents had him down was a Delta flight
nobody tells the nobody says to anybody
you got to put your mask on now listen
I don't like wearing masks okay but the
rules are right now you got to wear a
mask on a plane in eight days it looks
like they're gonna change it so when I
book a flight
I go oh I'm gonna have to wear a mask
that that's the rule I'm not going to be
the person breaking the rules I've
accepted I could have chosen to drive
I could have chosen to do whatever
those are the rules
not wearing their masks the whole flight
every time the mom gets up she does the
thing where she puts her hands on the on
the back of my seat and pulls herself up
and every time
I go back and every time she goes oh
sorry I'm sorry oh sorry but then she
does it again
and she does it again and she does it
again why is it I'm able to get up just
by putting my hands on the armrest and I
go Whoop I'm up
I don't have to start jerking around the
person in front of me
um next the kids are on iPads
with no headphones they have headphones
how do I know because the headphones are
plugged in to the seat back
entertainment and they're down on the
side you've got the headphones they plug
them in to the the plan entertainment
take out an iPad and it's all full
volume the parents say enough
the parents ain't nothing okay
kids throwing a tantrum the entire time
it would just I'm not even gonna go on
I'm not even gonna I'm not even gonna go
on uh oh and the other one funny thing
that happened but but just to like add
to it so I go into the bathroom and you
know how sometimes it's like there's the
cockpit tour and then there's the
bathroom door and they're right next to
each other and it gets very narrow right
there okay I he I'm in the bathroom and
I hear just a lot of commotion right out
like right outside the door like
someone's right outside the door
I opened the bathroom door
and the two kids and the dad are all
right there no masks of course they
they're they want to go in the bathroom
I opened the door and step out
the kids don't even let me move they
press me up against the cockpit door and
open the bathroom door so imagine the
absurdity I'm standing with my back to
the cockpit door and the bathroom door
is up against my face and the dad laughs
and goes
good thing you're thin and you can get
around my kids
I just look at the guy no mask of course
and just go back go back to my seat
um
the problem is the parents
right I mean it's not the kids the kids
are doing what they're allowed to get
away with and what they're always
allowed to get away from of course it's
the parents
um
it is a lot of America yeah and I yeah I
got right up close to the guy and I said
to him Obama and then
and then went back to my seat
really horrible I would call it domestic
terrorism quite frankly what these what
these kids did to the uh
what these kids did to the plane
uh dear God okay
we are standing by for Trump 25 minutes
away let's get to something positive
okay like this Super Chat David sir
what's up with the right wing in this
toxic sense of masculinity they so
afraid of being a beta male yes exactly
also I flushed the toilet in the in the
bathroom in the on the plane 10 to 15
times just in like in honor of trump
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times yep and then I even I even looked
really closely and I said
hi got him to think I was a little off
and then they went right back to their
seat behave the rest of the flight
no I'm kidding it was horror it was
really really horrible
um I also May usually I will bring
earplugs on on planes but because this
was like a daytime you know relatively
short flight five hours
um I didn't think to bring I have like
my kit and I just didn't bring my
overnight flight kit and normally I have
headphones sometimes they hand out
headphones on planes and they didn't
have any either so it was it was pretty
ugly it was very very ugly
ugly situation all right let's move on I
uh okay so here's what we've got going
on today from the standpoint of
membership we've got a lot of very very
exciting things first and foremost this
is really funny the other day I got an
email and someone said hey Pac-Man how's
that socialism thing working out for
your membership program huh and what I
realized they were referring to is that
I jokingly said we have a new way to
gift memberships and I said from each
according to their uh I don't even know
from each according to their ability
to each what what's the line can someone
give me the line I don't even remember
the line
God what is that line
from their need to their ability what is
it
oh people are still going crazy on the
uh flight stuff five hours is not a
short flight okay well
for me it's a relatively short flight
from each according to their
means and ability anyway I J from each
according to ability to each according
to need great the whole point was I said
people want to gift memberships on our
website okay so I went out and I found a
plug-in and we have the plugin so now
when you hit the sign up button on the
second page
there's this button this is a gift okay
and when you press that it gets into a
queue which I have to give away to
people
and I said the other day we have way
more people wanting free memberships
than we have giving free memberships and
the guy said this is the problem with
shows like yours this is the problem
with socialism this is the problem with
handouts way more people want the
handouts than the number that I can then
kind of that are willing to give them
out now my perspective is a little
different my perspective is well
many more people
uh are in a financial need where they
can't afford to buy memberships to a
show that they watch compared to people
who have a whole bunch of money and
could give away a thousand memberships
this is this is fact this is because we
have inequality in the United States and
we have inequality in the world now
people are saying David you should be a
capitalist I am a capitalist I jokingly
said that it's we have a membership
program we make money from advertising
okay so the whole point is if you have
this bell curve right
um and at the very top people could buy
everybody in my audience a membership
you know millions of people
so it's not really news that there are
more people that can't spend a couple
bucks on a membership for a show they
like than that so that's not really a
surprise really really strange from each
according to their mango Supply to es
exactly uh but in any case we have now
so here are the numbers and I actually
think these numbers show a lot of
generosity quite frankly we have now
given 75 memberships 75 memberships have
been gifted by people like you and we
have
had about 725 requested so what that
means is we have 650 people left who
still want a free membership I don't
actually think that that's terrible
that's not an insane ratio 75 gifted 725
requested right I think that that's okay
um
that's really not a big deal okay so
anyway the whole point here is if you're
watching and you don't have a membership
get a membership today if you can afford
it okay with the coupon code above my
head Obama and you've got to spell it
correctly with an N Obama you can get a
membership really really cheap
and if you have one or even if you don't
you can go through the sign up process
just just check this is a gift and then
we'll give it to someone you can give it
to someone if you know someone who wants
one if you leave it blank when it says
who do you want to send this to I will
give it to someone I have
647 people right now waiting for
memberships if you want a free
membership go to davidpackman.com free
membership fill out the form don't email
me don't tweet me don't Tick Tock me
don't send me a telegram don't leave me
a voicemail don't send me smoke signals
just fill out the form at
davidpackman.com free membership and if
you want to give one away then you can
check that box that says this is a gift
I'll give them away right on screen the
next person in line is David Meyer
okay so the next free one goes to David
Meyer
it's
nobody being strong-armed okay the
system's working fine we've given away
75 of them
it's great
all right so I will uh we'll start we'll
start naming folks as those come in
a couple of other super chats here
um sir what do you think of the idea of
registering as a republican so that I
could become a volunteer during
elections in my County they need
Republicans
what is that I don't even know they you
can't volunteer as a Democrat I don't
even get that I I'm just not sure I
understand
David sir can I get a happy birthday sir
28 Isaac happy birthday
and uh make it a good one 28 is a
beautiful number
appreciate it
okay a couple people signing up on you
Youtube very very good
Let's uh man there's a lot Happening
Here
as we stand by for Trump thank you to
Cortina jri agent 71 twerkzilla ruppled
twitch fish
whatever color durs jhtm one gifting
five that's 12 plus 12 hold on 12 plus
12. two plus two is four one plus one is
two that's 24.
very much appreciate that
um we have inequality and effort you get
paid what you provide to the market we
saw even with something as small as
stimulus check made people work less
okay
uh sir I saw Obama on Jimmy Kimmel
investigate yeah Jimmy Kimmel has now
meme jacked Obama as well it's really
really sad Obama
um but what I can't do anything about it
I mean everybody's taking Obama from me
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benell II stole
it Molina Destiny Bonnell II stole it
it's
it's sad really
creaky
is a new twitch Prime subscriber and is
number 25 I very much appreciate that
um
oh people want to see to hear one
Whitney voice I'll do one I'm only I
don't want to go down a Whitney rabbit
hole but let's do one Whitney voicemail
uh let's see here we go
we'll talk more about how come
um it looks like the empirical mindset
looks like it's on the left
um with Libertarians and I think it has
more to do with like conservatives but
um don't wait for like all the
information oh boy I hope people are
regretting asking for that
um and then I do have I think I have I
can do a Troy York as well
let's see
uh David packman
um oh there's a different guy Romanova
of the Epic times has pointed out Roman
balkanava okay that's uh
jeez
[Music]
remove d
uh calling first time long time Mr
Pacman uh I just can't I believe that uh
uh left-wing phonetics like to yourself
uh you always talk about Saudi Arabia
you oh it's so quick to to bring at the
human rights abuse in Saudi Arabia and
you talked about Trump in a video but
you you never quick to talk about the
more egregious uh
civil rights human rights abuses in
Venezuela Iran uh
China that's actually very untrue I talk
about what's going on in Venezuela all
the time and many in my audience don't
even like that I do because they don't
want to believe anything bad is
happening Iran's human rights abuses I
will admit I don't know as much about
what's going on in Iran and we just did
an interview with Jeffrey Kane about the
Civil Rights of Human Rights abuses in
China so Troy I'm just bored with Troy
it's kind of boring and pedantic I mean
I'm not gonna lie uh okay guys let's
give away some memberships look at the
great people we have in our audience
okay
Rachel has just gifted a membership okay
Rachel has just gifted a membership so
that's number 26.
we now give one to David Meyer David
Meyer now gets a membership because
Rachel gifted one do we see how that
works that's a beautiful thing next
Jacob has just gifted by the way a full
price membership okay so that's number
27 today and now thanks to Jacob's gift
Kelly Coleman gets a free membership so
we've now gifted 77 memberships total
there are 652 people still waiting
um okay also want to say thanks to Luis
razcone who just got a membership on my
website Jeff Adler
and David Fisher numbers 28 29 and 30.
this is a beautiful thing this is a
great day to get a membership get your
name up on the board let me give you an
extra incentive okay this is I think
people are going to like this because
people love free stuff they just love it
I was as I said I was cleaning out the
studio today everything's in a slightly
different place but we got a lot of the
dust off and everything's looking great
I came across I came across by the way
if we give two people many people gifted
memberships they're not going to want to
work we're going to have an unemployment
problem people are going to say I don't
need to work anymore I got a membership
our old logo which by the way is still
down there it's not even the logo we use
anymore the new logo is the one back
here okay I have not gotten that updated
but this is a this is a classic item I
found a bunch of bumper stickers with
the old logo
okay I will send a free bumper sticker
and literally it's going to be me doing
it I have a stack of them over there if
you get a membership on my website as
long as your payment is six dollars so
what do I mean by that what I mean is
you either get a full price monthly
which is six a month or you get a
discounted yearly for like 18 19 bucks
we just can't do it if people pay a
dollar ninety because these cost more
than two bucks and then we gotta mail it
we're not trying to lose money with if
if I wanted to torpedo the show's
finances I can think of other ways to do
it okay so you get a full price monthly
or a discounted yearly and you want one
of these we'll send it to you for free
it goes great on a MacBook it goes great
on a on a mini vehicle wherever you want
to put it but you've got to ask for it
you gotta email info at davidpackman.com
so this is an extra incentive does this
count for gifting memberships yes
it does if you gift a membership at six
dollars or whatever yearly you can also
get it the recipient now if you get a
free membership you can't also get this
that would be crazy
okay so it's it's all happening it's all
happening free we're giving everything
away giving it all away all right let's
see what else we've got here we did that
one
uh okay maybe a stupid question do I
need to create a new email address to
give a subscription no no in fact don't
do that
if you have a membership you can start
gifting them and they get attached to
your existing account you do not need no
do not use your existing please
signed up for a free Pacman membership
at the kiosk inside the Branson Missouri
Costco can't wait I would love to have a
kiosk inside of Costco where people can
request free memberships I think that
would be amazing
That'll be amazing
Ziggy's fix has given that Trump
actually believes none of the talking
points he spouts in the first place and
evidently has more left-wing beliefs
than right-wing beliefs why do you think
he ran as a republican only way he could
win
sir what do you think about Sheldon
Whitehouse as a Democratic presidential
candidate if Biden doesn't run I like uh
Jamie Raskin Moore
um but I think White House is an
interesting you know well-spoken guy but
I I I'm more partial to uh to Jamie
Raskin
how do we add gift memberships to the
pool asks tapson okay here's how you do
it
you go to joinpakman.com
you go through the sign up process and
when you see this page when it asks is
this a gift you check the box
this box here that's how you do it
do we are we on the same page
beautiful
and also will I do 2x on patreon why not
so if you go to patreon
okay
any patreon pledge
we will count it as two going towards a
hundred
is that fair I mean I think these are
these this has to be enough
I could also give away you know free hot
sauce but I don't know all right let's
gift some more memberships here guys
here we go Patrick Heinz has just gifted
a membership on my website that's number
31. the lucky recipient of that
membership is Ron Williams Ron
congratulations
Rachel Nelson has just gifted a
membership on our website the recipient
of Rachel's membership is Aries Javier
beautiful
next free membership goes from Marjorie
Milner Who is the gifter
the gifty is Christian dorius Christian
congratulations you get a free
membership
Keith sauce I like that
Keith sauce has just gifted a membership
and his new member number 34. the
recipient is Brian Lee Brian
congratulations thank you
Luciano Quinones has just gifted a
membership and is number 35. the
recipient is Barbara McHenry Barb way to
score
also want to say thanks to Juan trollman
Peralta
by the way a couple people emailed me
trying to correct my pronunciation of
Juan
guys you know you know I speak Spanish
right
people I couldn't tell if it was a joke
someone wrote in saying that they found
it strange that I sounded like I was
having a a cough when I say Juan that's
the way it's said in Spanish these
people who write to me telling me how to
speak Spanish it's
you know what goes through my mind when
I hear them say that throw them the hell
out of here yeah okay Juan trollman
Peralta is number 36 today
and the recipient is Daryl Gardner
uh okay all right and then people also
gifting uh getting themselves
memberships I want to say thanks to
James calivoda
and Jen Warden numbers 37 and 38. very
much appreciate that couple others are
coming in I will get to those also thank
you to Rachel link
zalkalwi nacho Jags can Workshop Dave
Schmidt another one from canned Workshop
another one from jhtm
all gifting subscriptions on Twitch
putting us at 44 and then a very
generous gift of five more subscriptions
from user what do we have here putting
us at 49. you know what guys just
because Juan did gift a subscription
uh I'll play one of Juan's recent
voicemails let me play one for you they
often are extremely trollish in nature
or just misunderstandings of things Juan
heard Okay let's listen
hey David it's Juan I like your piece
and Juan even mispronouncing his own
name that's like that I've I only know
two people who have mispronounced their
own names Juan and Trump then he went
down Trump yeah yeah Donald Trump okay
anyway here we go uh Amendment Oz
um I like your uh
food recommendations with the vegetables
and all of that
you got the canola part wrong but
everything else was fought on as far as
uh the midterms for the Democrats
um
I don't know man uh
I don't know what to tell you but I can
tell you that
before Trump I really didn't care about
politics
and Trump got me involved in politics
this voicemail is Meandering Quan it's
not your best work necessarily why do
you think I'm calling you so often I
wish I could rewind and just do other
things instead of focusing on stupid
political crap all right well
you're not here under threat of uh you
know hanging exactly Juan but okay I
really do appreciate his um
the gifted membership though very much
appreciate that okay let's see what else
we have coming in here via Super Chat
there should be an option to gift
multiple website subscriptions 10 2100
yeah that that's on let me make sure
that's on my list for our web dev she's
got to get on that this week uh okay so
did I have that on my list
um
multi membership gifts yeah I actually I
need to check with the developer of the
tool of the of the plug-in but I would
like it to be easier because right now
to gift five subscriptions you got to go
through the process five times that's a
little much to ask people to do okay
other super chats Disney is the rate
latest right wing cancel culture Target
people from all over the world come to
these Parks why would Disney not want to
embrace diversity absolutely
100 percent
shout out to the Deepak book club go to
the Discord server to join this much
this month we will be reading Brian
carem's latest book great yeah there is
a book club on the Discord
beautiful thing
Tristan says regarding the plane we hate
all the same things this Behavior seems
to have gotten much worse of over the
years do you think Trump be it trumpism
is solely responsible no but it is
partially responsible that's that's fair
sir please explain is a gifted
membership valid for as long as the Gift
Giver pays does that do they expire
exactly yeah if you gift a monthly
subscription you've given it for a month
you're not going to get rebuild you
don't we understand you're only gifting
one month and then then it's done and
then the recipient can choose to extend
or not if you if you gift a year it's
valid for a year you won't get rebuild
if the person wants to continue they can
do it uh absolutely we would not I mean
that it would be crazy to do it any
other way my friends we would not do it
any other way
uh thanks to the last Outlaw as well as
rain flush and crowbars forever for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
52. I've got more membership gifts to
give away let's do okay so first let me
do the people getting themselves
memberships that's Brandon Spencer let's
go Brandon beautiful
uh uh panuro SE Lucy I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly
uh let's see
Christian Mazer Jack
Quentin Thatcher
Lorna Cronk Jesse panknen
Jolena Woodruff Jane Wright
that six new members getting themselves
memberships Grace left court has made a
patreon pledge those count double today
I'm gonna need a calculator soon I think
all right now let's get to the gifts
people very very excitedly
uh awaiting various gift elements Drew
misco and Dustin Mason have just gifted
two subscriptions the recipients are
Drake War Barry
and Talia Smith congratulations
kailani Silva
and Tiffany mclay have gifted two more
the recipients there are Keith Peters
and Andreas nishack
love it
and then Joseph Pierce has gifted a
membership so has Josh Tweedy putting us
at 66 the recipients there are Stacy
Seeley and Katrine Corona
all right last two Patty Holly
and Joseph Pierce putting us at 68 the
lucky recipients are Mitch Lee now
and Jason grout if you would like to get
a free membership fill out the form at
davidpackman.com free membership if you
would like to give a free membership
check the this is a gift box when you're
going through the sign up process
oh by the way the Patty thing reminded
me
for whatever reason YouTube recommended
to me this UFC fighter Patty pimlet or
is it Patty pimlet or pimler
is it pimp I think it's pimlet Patty
pimlet
anybody know who I'm talking about
nobody's heard him great okay so nobody
knows
um no okay it's pimlet this UFC fighter
Patty pimlet is for Liverpool
the act the Liverpool accent is just
it's otherworldly and he actually has a
pretty funny YouTube channel so I'm
gonna try inviting him onto the show I
don't even know what I guess I would
talk to him about being from Liverpool
and UFC what's it like when you get
knocked out and stuff like that I'm just
fascinated the guy is fascinating so
we're gonna try to get him on the show
Pat producer Pat was like what it what
would be the topic I was like I don't
even know but it just sounds interesting
um
so we're going to try to do that I think
it'll be an interesting uh
interesting crossover event for the
David packman show
hey David I heard you're learning French
what platform are you using no I'm
really not I I took French for years and
years and I speak perfectly fine
conversational French in fact when I
went to a Vineyard in France
I somehow I communicated only in French
in French with the uh
with the owner of the vineyard
uh but I'm not I'm not studying it
currently
I could always use some practice though
I want to say thank you to z-ball who
just gifted a massive
uh 20 subscriptions 20 subscriptions on
the on on Twitch in fact
exactly really appreciate that very very
much
also want to say thank you to the the
website is uh is is doing everything it
can to stay
up because of the activity Laura Palmer
and keilani Silva just got themselves
memberships that puts us at 90.
also I have two more gifts to give away
uh a user named Cole who made a pun that
would have me say something very very
blue Cole has gifted a subscription so
has Susan duzumon
or decimon and those gifts are going to
Ryan aquafredda and Eduardo Ortega thank
you also Michael Brownstein is a new
member that's number 93. the website is
under heavy pressure guys I'm not gonna
lie very very heavy pressure on the
website
all right let's listen in and see what
each of these strange streams are
covering
Newsmax is just silent
weird okay here's right side
broadcasting the shocking
changes that have been made in a short
period of time weakening us in our
economy weakening our our schools
weakening our our the fabric of this
nation and weakening the whole work
that's called fear reactionary porn
that's what we call that and then here
is the real America's voice stream
is that Ed Henry what the hell is he
doing he used to be like a real
reporter wasn't he what the hell is that
Henry doing here
that is humiliating on the camera and
probably about 10 over on the other side
so I I think we're getting pretty close
yeah because they were not there this
Channel's also the audio is completely
out of sync with the video we're
probably not going to be able to stick
with this one though behind where we are
and he could be back there typically he
has a a special area that's secure of
course with campaign donors and Friends
supporters Matt Whittaker who is here
before VIPs like that we'll go back in a
couple seconds maybe take a photo and
then we'll see him come out
all right so let's talk about the
atmosphere now as I'm sure a lot of
people know he is getting ready I have
to tell you if that is that Henry he
doesn't seem too thrilled to be there uh
and I could understand that again you
know I earlier we came up with the term
fetid Sani cans uh that is sort of the
trademark of these uh Trump events thank
you to imar cousin
for the twitch Prime subscription I
appreciate that
uh is that Hemi lifestyle says Trump is
in Selma North Carolina that's where I
was raised Johnston County is known it's
known for a lot of rednecks years ago
they got rid of the KKK sign years ago
good
good not a big fan of KKK signs I want
to say thanks to uh okay to Giannis I
don't think that the person signing up
is really a Greek professional
basketball player but they're wanting me
to to think that they are thanks Giannis
uh you are new member number 95. it's a
gift so the recipient is Doug Ragsdale
Doug you get a free membership it's an
incredible day it really is and I can't
tell you how much I appreciate you being
here let's get a couple of other Clips
up from the behind the scenes and the
early at the Trump rally
um let's see here
what do we have oh actually we don't we
don't really seem to have anything
here's one let's see
[Music]
[Applause]
in Washington this week
a court acquitted a January 6 defendant
charged by the doj with felonies
isn't that imagine they're all cheering
wow okay all right so that's that let's
see if our friend Ron Phillip Phillip
Kowski
has any more things here
at Matt Gates re-election kickoff Marge
green says after they impeach Biden for
Hunter's laptop they'll impeach Kamala
okay
before I play the clip do you guys think
she correctly pronounces Kamala or does
she mispronounce Kamala in this clip
I've not listened to this clip what do
people think
correct or incorrect
on the pronunci from the standpoint of
pronunciation
wow everybody's saying mispronounce
all right let's let's listen
[Applause]
Kamala Harris
you guys were right you guys are right
mispronouncing it
yeah I don't know if it's intentional at
this point either to be totally honest
yeah you you guys were a hundred percent
correct there
uh all right we've really kind of gone
over all the clips that they have over
there so we are just moments away
from uh from Donald Trump here I read
that uh that Hunter Biden would not
regularly do Windows updates on the on
the laptop from hell and that's what
made it so hellish it was it didn't have
all the right security patches or
anything it's like what can you expect
David sir please be aware Don Jr has
operational control tonight he will not
allow massive dumps to hurt America okay
what's going on here homework and
research to see with pillow corruption
the level of corruption wait a second is
that Mike pillow using a phone phones
are a form of machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah
that's weird thank you David for all you
do big fan of yours I actually met
Kamala Harris in Goldsboro North
Carolina a year ago and did a speech for
her beautiful
that's good stuff I want to say thank
you to Lynn Hansen Lynn is our newest
member so remember if you were just
joining us as they show some kind of Joe
Biden video first of all anybody who
signs up oh my God not this video it's
not that video was that sped up weirdly
that was that was really strange uh
anybody who gets a membership
and makes a payment of at least six
dollars meeting you meaning you pay full
price for a month or you get a discount
for a year I will send out no longer
available classic classic David Pacman
show bumper stickers to you you gotta
email info davidpackman.com full price
monthly or any yearly membership you
will qualify for a free bumper sticker
and number two I have 661 people waiting
they're just sitting there waiting
praying calling whatever whatever people
do flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
awaiting a free membership and you can
gift them one when you sign up on my
website and check the box is this a gift
and then we will we will give them away
I have a couple more to give away here
thanks to Austin swan
uh and wait a second Rebecca Rose I have
two more gifts to give away these go to
Jeff gelber and Mark Lancaster As Trump
is making his way on let's see if the
song is playing
foreign
it is it is I also want to say thanks to
Penny Cruz you are number 99 today and
getting us to 100 is Kyoko awaya who I
can only imagine is our great friend who
calls in from Tokyo and talks to me
about miso soup and katsuboshi and so
many different things uh and that gift
goes to Lorenzo walls
what a night people are just going crazy
also thank you to family media as well
as blueberry babe for gifting some
subscriptions putting us at 103 we will
see uh whether it is upper Trump or
downer Trump today
maybe one more Super Chat thought Trump
would have been watching the Masters but
I guess rallies are better for his ego
love the tacky pop-up on-screen ads for
gold and pillows especially when they
pop up while Trump speaks I know it's
it's it is weird
it's all pretty crass that that goes on
at these rallies
uh and we're going to be hearing from
Donald Trump momentarily my My Hope Is
since he's starting early that he wants
to get out it looks like it might be a
little chilly for him that will usually
squeeze it down to like 40 minutes which
is much better than the hour and a half
diatribes
a big thank you to Kyoko for a second
gift as well as Rebecca putting us at
105. those gifts go to Karthik and Chris
Kerr
let's listen to the uh failed former
president Donald Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
expect dangerous cult Behavior both from
the guy on the stage and the people in
the crowd no sign of blacks for Trump
they've been missing from the last
couple rallies very much
thank you very much that's great this is
a big crowd of people
thank you Selma we love to be in Selma
and we've had some great experiences
here and very slurry tonight almost like
the teeth are getting in the way there
Carolina
[Applause]
11 months from now the people of North
Carolina are going to vote to fire the
radical left Democrats you're going to
send
the very great man he's a great man I've
known him a long time he's a tremendous
person Ted Budd to the U.S Senate
Ted Bud thank you Ted you're going to
elect an incredible slate of true
America First Republicans
up and down the ballot you will go and
together the audio quality guys is on
them antifa must be running audio today
I don't know
she's crazy
the stakes this November could not be
higher Biden and the Congressional
Democrats triggered runaway inflation
the supply chain disaster how about that
do you go to a store you don't have
anything on the shelves whoever even
hurts I think there's five million
people at the speech American Energy and
now the middle class is being crushed by
the highest gas in food prices in the
history of our country
violent criminals are being set loose
and democrat-run cities to prey on
innocent citizens there's never been
anything like the crime that we're
witnessing in the democrat-run cities
while radical left judges persecute
Republicans and whole political
prisoners without trial
our children are being indoctrinated our
values are being desecrated our heritage
is being he's slurring worse than ever
and going through the speech very
quickly so it could be just that it's
chilly
or he just wants to not be there
[Applause]
so what's happening the simple fact is
the presidential election was rigged and
stolen to be because of that
because of that our country is being
systematically destroyed we have a
President Who is challenged
but he's surrounded by vicious evil and
very corrupt people who are doing
whatever they want to in running our
country to ruin with your vote this
November we can stop our nation's
decline we can make America great again
and that's what we're going for
of all the many catastrophes Biden has
Unleashed perhaps none is more
horrendous than his ruthless abolition
of America's borders remember the Border
we had the strongest Border in the
history of our country a year and a half
ago by the way time is flying you know
we used to say four years
in three years now the other day I heard
him say two and a half years two and a
half years doesn't sound so bad four
years sounded like a long time
the problem is Marco we're going to have
a country left two and a half years is
still long Max silco no destruction
they've done in this short time is
Unthinkable with last week's
announcement that the Biden
Administration will rescind The crucial
title 42 protections that I put into
place to quickly remove illegal aliens
that's to remove the illegal aliens and
very very quickly and even the fake news
knows that one was a good one that's a
lot of people back there
welcome welcome
fake news welcome
Biden is willfully opening the
floodgates to a tidal wave of illegal
immigration the likes of which the world
has never seen before no country no
country has this ever happened to East
deliberately inciting a mob of millions
and millions of foreign Nationals to
illegally infiltrate America's borders
violate our laws trample our sovereignty
and settle in our country frankly it's
an invasion you can call it whatever you
want but this is an invasion a lot of
dehumanizing language releasing
releasing immigrants like you would
release an animal uh invasion you guys
I'm sure you're familiar with this by
now very very uh vile MS-13 gang members
to victimize American citizens we will
be paying a very big price for This
calamity marked by words for a long
period of time
what's coming into our country is going
to leave a mark for many many years and
decades probably unfortunately it's uh
crazy it's crazy when you think of it oh
sounds like he wouldn't be able to fix
it if he was given four years if it's
going to be decades we had the strongest
border ever not even a contest
the Washington Democrats believe our
country should be one giant Sanctuary
for dangerous criminal aliens in the
Republican party we believe our country
should be a sanctuary for law abiding
Americans
we had the safest border and now we have
the worst border we've ever had
and I mean that no country I don't care
if it's a third world country has ever
had a worse border situation than us
they wouldn't allow people to come in
like this you know there's some pretty
crazy border situations around the world
and what's going on here is not really
that high on the list compared to some
other places
it's meanwhile Biden and the radical
Democrats are spending billions and
billions of dollars trying to secure the
borders of distant foreign Nations many
nations that you've never even heard of
before I believe Americans deserve a
president who will secure the borders of
our nation
who will protect our citizens who will
defend our sovereignty and who will stop
the invasion of our country right now
what's happening is Unthinkable after we
win this November Republicans should
immediately vote to remove Biden's
Secretary of Homeland Security
how many people in the crowd you think
know who the Secretary of Homeland
Security is for his blatant acts of
sabotage against the laws of the United
States and then we should continue to
work hard until the borders are again
sealed
and we want people to come into our
country but we want them to come into
our country legally
you could take the five worst Presidents
in American history and put them
together and they would not have done
the damage Joe Biden has done Oh I
thought he was going to say as much as
that much damage as he did in months as
everyone is saying Russia's outrageous
invasion of Ukraine would never have
happened and I mean it would never have
happened
if I was in the White House and not even
a chance would have never happened every
time I look at
those scenes and television and the
scenes that you see in your papers every
time I look I get sick to think about it
because all of those people that are
dying and all of those people that are
dead have been killed savagely killed
horribly killed they would be alive
today they wouldn't even be thinking
about it that would have never happened
under our Administration America was
strong and America was respected because
you had a president who always put
America first
Trump put himself first who are we
kidding
[Music]
by the way we have a group of incredible
women incredible Patriots I think
they've come how many rallies have you
been to and we will
man tell me the number they don't want
to say because their husbands may be
watching
what is it like 78 or something the nice
part is they live here this time they
live there so
they live in North Carolina but they've
been traveling and they do a lot of them
and they're sick people thank you
easily recognizable they're also perfect
I mean I've never seen anything so
beautiful thank you very much for
traveling thank you
the radical left Democrats put America
last that's what they do they put
America last and all you have to do is
look at what they're doing and that's
where they want to keep us they want to
keep us last you would never think that
but after watching what they do and the
craziness I think it's probably true the
Biden Administration has been one
disgraceful surrender
after another starting with the
catastrophic way in which we withdrew
from Afghanistan was that the lowest
some people are saying the audio is
better here let's see princess hostages
surrendering Bagram Air Base to China
China has it we were going to keep it it
cost billions and billions of dollars to
build many years ago one hour away from
where China makes their nuclear weapons
so we gave it away and of course giving
away famously 85 billion dollars worth
of the finest military equipment in the
world we gave it to the Taliban
seven hundred thousand rifles machine
guns guns of all seven hundred thousand
listen to this one though
seventy thousand trucks seventy thousand
is there a car company in the country
that has seventy thousand cars trucks
what do you think Ted I don't think so
right I don't think so seventy and many
of them armor plated costing millions of
dollars millions of dollars now Biden is
continuing to surrender parade begging
Iran to re-enter the disastrous nuclear
deal that I terminated very proudly and
very powerfully strongly had the
election not been rigged we would have
had a deal with Iran within one week
from the election now Iran is becoming
rich again because China's buying and
they're all buying and we've driven the
price of oil up so high the highest in
the history of oil
and it's a disgrace they're pleading
also with the Venezuelan dictator to
sell us oil think of that one so they
want oil from Venezuela now when we have
it right under our feet it's called
Liquid Gold we're sitting on liquid gold
and we're going to buy it from Venezuela
and other countries and we have it under
our feet here's gas prices remember
energy independent we have exactly the
highest double the size of Russia and
Saudi Arabia put together within one
year
it's a far cry from the Trump
Administration when we were totally
energy independent and gasoline was
costing less than two dollars a gallon
remember those days of a year and a half
ago a dollar 87 a gallon for a car now
you know what everyone's saying let's
buy a smaller car darling we don't like
this big so it was 220
15 months ago not a dollar 87 a year ago
it's I mean do the facts even matter
does anyone care about the facts and
send gas prices soaring with The Fringe
left-wing energy policies inspired by
these socialist joke known as the Green
New Deal windmills
windmills we want windmills all over the
place I don't see any windmills here the
noise because you see these towers that
are holding up the lights
those towers are tiny compared to the
windmills if you are near a windmill and
you have a house your house is like
pretty much worthless
kills all the birds ruins your
Landscapes and it's the most expensive
form of energy there is if Biden wanted
those are all lives for gas prices
tomorrow all he has to do is come out
and publicly admit that his
anti-American energy policies were 100
percent wrong and the pro-american
energy policies of a certain president
that you like literally just lost the
contact lens it just chopped out
all right I got to go put that back in
wow I can't see a thing I'll be back
we're 100 right
100
.
they're going to be very famous
they're going to be very famous tonight
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you that's
beautiful
great state it's been a great state
it's a slogan you're hearing more and
more across the country and it is true
and it's not about me it's about us
because we all like kids you know what
it is it's really Common Sense somebody
said are you conservative
somebody actually said are you liberal
no I'm not liberal
but it's not even a question of being
conserved you know what it is it's
common sense it's like we want a strong
military we want a good education we
want a beautiful home for as little as
possible we want so many things we want
a strong military we love our law
enforcement we're not going to defund
them we're going to give them much more
we love our Lawns ice cream
we want voter ID when you walk in people
want to see what does he look like
yes sir my left contact just fell out I
just had to put it back in choices
November is very simple if you want high
crime high prices high taxes High
corruption and high incompetence vote
for the radical Democrats if you want a
country that is strong Sovereign solvent
safe and secure
you really have to vote for America
First Republicans it's common sense
so we're joined this evening and this is
a beautiful evening you know we were in
South Carolina a few weeks ago and
what a great place but it was cold right
it was cold we had I think the coldest
night ever on record that's not true we
had a hell of a crowd too we looked it
up at the time it was that's also what
like why does he have to tell these lies
beautiful 80
s but I broke Elvis Presley's record I
was
there were not 87 000 people at his
rallied there were 5 000 people
[Applause]
bad voice
we're joined this evening by some of the
incredible Patriots who are going to
send the Democrat extremists out of
Washington in disgrace in particular
with us tonight is the man who is going
to help and Chuck Schumer's brief I like
how he says particular verticular sounds
more like a medical condition verdigular
your next senator from the great state
of North Carolina Ted Bud Ted
what a great guy he is I knew it
you know he had a poll today I won't
tell you what it is I'm not going to
tell you what this poll was but you know
his district loved him some people
didn't know him but now why won't he
tell us if I was getting calls from the
best and strongest and toughest and
smartest Congress men and women and
they're saying Ted Bud Ted Bud
Laura said Ted buddy for the people that
know Trump know to only speak 30 seconds
and it all has to be praising Trump
because otherwise he'll get bored and
upset they're great people and Don and
Ivanka we have a wonderful
family
and Tiffany's getting married and baron
is so tall and handsome now and
and a good student too
but you know they were all saying about
Ted and Ted Bud really is they said it
is an unrelenting Champion for your
North Carolina values and for America
first he wants America first they want
Ted America last can be nothing else
Ted's been a ferocious opponent of
deadly Sanctuary cities right here in
your state you have Sanctuary cities you
didn't even know that he fought strongly
against the Democrats unscientific
covert lockdowns and school closures
which were absolutely hurting your
children so badly and he has shown he
will stand up to the Rhinos you know we
do have some rhinos you do know about
in many ways a bad Rhino is worse than a
Democrat because you don't know where
they're coming from but we sort of have
a pretty good idea right
but just as bravely he stands up for the
crowd that's here today this is an
incredible group of people great
Patriots and you love our country and we
love Ted for doing this takes a lot of
courage to do it takes a lot of Courage
but so I won't tell you about the poll I
won't tell you about the result I will
not say that he has a 17-point lead oops
I don't
know that's a big lead
I saw one where he's 10 points one was
12 points and uh one was 17 points up
over the bathroom Governor you know the
bathroom Governor remember the bathroom
Governor what a mess that was
but Ted is a fantastic man and he'll
defend your borders he will be tough as
hell on crime he will protect our
constitution by voting only for judges
who interpret the laws as written and as
a gun store owner or maybe I'll see him
I want to buy a gun
Ted will never let them take away one of
the funniest things Trump does is he
reads the prompter like he's reading an
article and he'll then react to it like
he just did it there it's it's an
amazing thing it's incredible
Mr President I think that I can speak
for all of us in North Carolina tonight
when we say we are glad to have Donald J
Trump back in North Carolina
sure sure
and we will ban men
thank you
Mr President
well Mr President the last time that you
were here I said that we are ready to
get back to working with you to make
America great again
right and Mr President we mean that now
more than ever Joe Biden's America is
woke and broke and we can't fact we
can't back down the fight starts now I'm
the America First candidate Mr President
thank you let's go win this for our
country
that's how you have to do a speech in
these situations you do 30 seconds and
it's mostly just praising Trump very
proud of that and
not in easy thing to do what he's doing
and he did it so well and what is he
doing we got to get out there and vote
make sure you're voting and we're going
to have somebody very special and
another man who's very special because
just today and this man is respected
from the first day I heard his name
everyone said he's incredible he's so
great
he's a man uh yeah that's right Buck
that's right he just gave Ted a very big
endorsement he's a conservative Warrior
more importantly he's a brilliant guy
and unlike any other
people in this practically in this
country I'll tell you what he is going
places this guy right here keeps yawning
and covering his mouth with a sign when
he yawns it's pretty funny
they love this guy
there's a really interesting thing that
the Trump crowds will do whenever a
black person speaks they cheer extra
almost like to prove how not racist they
are it's very interesting look I am a
guy who just a few years ago I was
working in a
and now today I am standing on stage in
Johnston County with the president of
the United States of America
does the crowd know Trump's not the
president right now
[Applause]
dream is not dead it's alive and well
it's not even on life support
and Trump's help in 2024 we're going to
make that more clear than ever we're
going to make it more clear in 22 when
we put Ted blood in office we're going
to make America great again and we're
going to bring back what makes this
country work which is conservative
principles God bless you Mr President
thank you for everything and God bless
all of y'all thank y'all
what an inspirational message
thanks Greg
the shoulders on that man see the
shoulder he's a great man the primary is
on May 17th but early voting begins on
April 28th so get out there I don't
understand if it's rigged why do they
bother voting does that make sense to
anybody point two but we had no problem
in North Carolina they did a great job
oh in North Carolina it's not rigged
okay best candidate in this race and we
will crush the radical Democrat nominee
in November I need each and every one of
you to remember that so important when
you're a senator representing a state
it's so powerful it's so important for
the country not only the state Ted bud
you got to get out and vote for them and
we have some other warriors with us
tonight also with US representatives
friends of mine Dan Bishop Dan thank you
very much
great guy
Greg Murphy
thank you Greg great job
a man I love him because he's never
controversial there's no controversy
pillow but you know what he loves his
country he loves this state and I'll
tell you he is respected all over the
place he's got a big voice Madison
Hawthorne oh God
oh boy
foreign
candidate for North Carolina's 13th
congressional district Beau Hines
and we will baseball men handsome guy I
don't know who's better looking him or
Madison I don't know
[Applause]
and you know Bo you have my complete and
total endorsement okay of course
a man who has done an incredible job you
know you read all about these scams and
all of the fake quotes and all of the
everything but we didn't have that
problem in North Carolina because we
have a chairman Michael Whatley who has
been just incredible Michael
thank you related to Dr Tim Whatley the
Seinfeld dentist played by Brian
Cranston of course Michael great job
really a great job and good luck with
the race I think you're going to have
tremendous success
a David McIntosh is a very powerful man
he's the head of the club for growth and
a very good friend of mine and Club for
Growth is really an organization that no
one talks about anymore they were big
like I think in the Clinton era and into
Bush and you know kind of like a we're
fiscally conservative and you know see
he wants to come up hey David come up
and say a few words you know this guy
used to be a congressman hurry up David
I don't know they said who the hell is
that David McIntosh reportedly is the
cousin of Tim Apple thank you Mr
President Mr President you are a great
man that are once again going to lead
this country back to Freedom
foreign
I'm so proud to partner with you to
elect Ted Budd to re-elect Madison to
re-elect Bishop to re-elect Greg and to
reelect Beau Heinz or elect Beau Hines
for the first time right we're gonna do
it
it's gonna do it it's all of these great
Americans from North Carolina God bless
you it is incredible how quickly Trump
gets bored when other people speak it's
it's notable David very much great guy
he's a fighter that guy
I used to fight against him it wasn't
pleasant
we decided let's get together
and a man that nobody's ever heard of
because he's very shy on television
hates putting out television commercials
he's the greatest buyer of Television
ads and history Mike Lindell Mike we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines
oh what a love story
what a love story thank you Sheriff
thank you very much and then we fell in
love from the border nightmare to the
inflation nightmare from the energy
crisis to the violent crime crisis and
from the Afghanistan disaster to the
Ukraine disaster everything we're seeing
is a consequence of this horrible
horrible election it was rigged it was
stolen it was a disgrace but don't lose
hope because with the right leadership
America will be back greater stronger
and more powerful than ever before the
truth is I ran twice I won twice I did
much better the second time well then
you can't run again
that's the law
we may have to do it again
what
is there anybody here who would like to
see me run again
not bad here I'll remember I'm
increasingly thinking Trump's not going
to run and my view today is different
than it was 10 days ago I'm going to
talk about it on the Monday show
thank you
what a cult huh
I remember that I'm gonna remember that
time is moving along over our four
incredible years we accomplished more
than any Administration in the history
of our country and in so many different
ways we passed the largest tax cuts and
reforms in American history
we cut a record number of job-killing
regulations in addition to energy
Independence and cheap gasoline we
approve the Keystone XL pipeline which
they immediately ended and we got built
the Dakota access pipeline these are big
ones and opened Anwar for energy
development and by the way we ended the
Russian Pipeline you do know that right
unfortunately this group came in and
they immediately approved it and then
they say Trump treated Russia so nicely
I don't think so we appointed nearly 300
federal judges to defend our
constitution that's a tremendous number
like people have not even thought
possible and has made a tremendous
difference in the courts we confirmed
three incredible Supreme Court Justices
we eliminated the founder and leader of
Isis al-baghdadi and we terminated the
world's top terrorist qasim solomoni
will we talk about Abdul nearly two and
a half trillion dollars in new fighter
jets aircraft carriers tanks and
missiles for our military and we created
the first new branch of the United
States armed forces in over 75 years
since the Air Force it's called the
space force
very important
you think anybody there has any idea
what space force is doing veterans we
passed VA accountability
oh
Trump doesn't like interruptions to his
speech and incredible oh these people
don't know what the hell they're doing
the bike
but there is a trump fan
now of course if that was Amtrak it's
not exactly someone who would be
cheering for Trump they'd be cheering
for Biden
what the hell
Ted I think he's a voter of yours
but it's a beautiful train which I tried
to give less money to when I was
president
isn't that a beautiful sound to me it's
a beautiful sound but we pass for the
Vets VA accountability and vehicles
they've been trying to get that to pass
for 55 years think of it VA
accountability VA choice we passed right
to try you know what right to try is we
created peace look at that he's still
hunking that hard we love that guy
man
and look at that trade that's the
longest train I've ever seen the Locust
train stop but he's happy he's gonna go
home and he's gonna tell his wife baby
we saw Trump and we saw a dead bud and I
honked the hell out of that train
we love we love those guys Ted
we created peace in the Middle East with
historic and you know what the Abraham
Accords are we created peace we would
have had them all signed up no one there
knows and we fought for fair and
reciprocal trade for workers of North
Carolina you know you're doing better
than you've ever done I withdrew from
the terrible trans-pacific partnership
which would have destroyed your
automobile industry and many other
Industries we ended the NAFTA disaster
the worst trade deal ever made and
replace it with the Brand New
usmca Mexico and Canada the best trade
deal this is a very well done Super Chat
a train came up to me a big strong train
and it was crying and it said sir thank
you that I can honk my horn again big
strong train very long the
administration don't do it
because that was a horrible deal NAFTA
for many many years we had to live with
it we have a great deal now don't change
it we created half a million new
manufacturing jobs in my first year they
said they said this it will never happen
manufacturing is dead remember they said
Barack Hussein Obama he said
manufacturing is dead in our country I
said how the hell is that possible
and we created tremendous manufacturing
jobs to be a strong Nation America must
be a manufacturing Nation we cannot be
reliant on China or the craziest part is
most of this is being read from a
teleprompter and it's still this
disjointed it's like who's writing it on
his plunder and pillage of American jobs
and industries like no president in
history we charge China hundreds of
billions of dollars when no other
president charged them 10 cents not 10
cents he still doesn't know how tariffs
work or his speechwriter doesn't they
pay
[Music]
some manufacturers getting them the
largest
agricultural purchase orders ever in the
history of our country from China we
fought for North Carolina and we won for
North Carolina and when Republicans we
take Congress we will fight and win for
North Carolina once again
one of the first things that we will do
with our new Republican majorities is to
end every last coveted mandate they're
still around are there any coveted
mandates still does anybody know of any
I don't know
I guess masks on planes which ends in
nine days the bill making it illegal for
any employer to interfere in personal
health decisions or to fire employees
for not having the vaccine Trump's
really the guy to lead on covid because
he was just so right when he said we
have 15 cases and it'll soon be zero
Democrat Party politicians and the
teachers unions to keep our children out
of school for no scientific reason
whatsoever
the irreversible harm the Democrat
politicians did to our young people is
unforgivable and American voters will
punish them
at The Ballot Box this November
despite all your hearing and seeing of
China and Russia and Iran and others our
biggest danger is not from outside
coming in our biggest single danger is
from the sick and radical politicians
that are knowingly or unknowingly
wanting to destroy our country
foreign
I believe that I as president I was
proud to sign the world's first band
on critical race Theory
and we will ban men the Biden
Administration rescinded that order but
when we retake Congress Republicans will
ban the critical race theory in our
schools ban it in our military ban it in
every part of federal state and local
governments just like they're they're
very much for free speech guys
but they will ban something not even
being taught in many places parental
right
parental choice I think that's
again everything I
am the virus
allowed to teach far left gender
theories to our children without
parental consent what is a far left
gender Theory anyway
plain and simple by replacing reading
and math with pronouns and gender
studies our government-run education
system has forfeited the trust of
American parents I read Trump wants to
ban whole grain mustard that has like
the full mustard seeds in there because
he thinks they look too much like fish
eggs doesn't like it the indoctrination
and send their child to the public
private Charter or religious school of
their choice
have to do it
last week
the Biden Administration sent Congress a
budget crammed with billions and
billions of dollars of transgenderism
and so-called Equity Provisions that are
nothing more than
I have I would love to have millions in
of transgenderism in a bank account that
sounds interesting it will end the woke
war on women and children we will stop
illegal government discrimination we
will restore the sacred American
principle of equality under the law
and we will while we're at it Trump's
the type of guy that would try to ban
spicy food you know who's in full
protection
[Applause]
life was received by antifa and black
lives matter who murdered people
throughout our country
and as you probably have heard one of
the first January six trials ended
in an extortion and it was a horrible
thing what they were doing to people but
there was exoneration
because they effectively proved
that he got waved into the capital by
the police
remember this Nancy Pelosi was in charge
of
the capital you know that right and the
mayor of DC they were in charge of all
Securities the mayor of DC that's like
the main horse of DC or on January 3rd
ten thousand soldiers or National Guard
to protect the capital they turned it
down if they would have accepted that
they're in charge of it if and we
offered it if they would have accepted
that there would have been no January 6
as we know it if Trump didn't incite a
riot there also wouldn't have been one
quite famous Michigan
trouble were supposedly
very strange to a lot of people
two were just found not guilty and two
others ended in a hung jury so there's
something going on down there there's
something going on the radical Democrat
Party will do anything to stop our
movement no matter how illegal immoral
or insane now in New York state as an
example the extreme left is continuing
the greatest Witch Hunt
it's the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
have you been hearing about this
no failed New York state gubernatorial
candidate
Leticia James
who recently ran
for governor and had to give up because
she had no support she had almost no
poll numbers her parties
is no longer working as the Attorney
General she went back into the Attorney
General's office as a
political operative for the Democrat
Party
political persecution and abusing her
powers for her own personal gain it's
prosecutorial misconduct and it began
the second I came down the escalator
with our great future first lady that
was of course the inspirational day
where he said Mexico's not sending their
best they're sending criminals and
rapists in an attempt to silence a
president who is leading in every single
poll by a lot
never before has this happened to
another president and it is truly an
absolute violation of civil rights in my
opinion and your civil rights too
I've been investigated by the Democrats
more than Billy the Kid Jesse James and
Al Capone combined
and in all cases I've been innocent
we have a great Sheriff right here
where's the sheriff I stand up Cheryl
getting sad
we want to send the sheriff into New
York clean things up Sheriff
[Applause]
but you know there's never been anything
like it it just never stops a friend of
mine smart guy very successful guy a lot
of common sense he said you know you've
been investigated
for years and years millions and
millions of pages of documents they
found nothing you are the cleanest guy
on earth when you think about it I've
got to be the cleanest Sheriff I think
I'm the most honest human being perhaps
that God ever created there you go
instead of persecuting Republicans these
Rogue Democrat prosecutors should stop
the crime and the Bloodshed that is
Raging uncontrollably and democrat-run
cities and states
and New York Leticia James New York has
got disastrous numbers up a record
amount 50 percent more number one number
one for going up so Leticia James should
be focusing on New York not focusing on
let's get Trump a list of out all the
time let's get Trump we've only been
doing this for years
with record murders surging violence and
drug trafficking at the highest level
we've ever had a lot of drug trafficking
the witch hunts have to end
the depravity and Corruption of our
left-wing political establishment cannot
be overstated just this week special
counsel John Durham outlined in court
filings to quote joint venture or
conspiracy by Democrat operatives and
officials to perpetrate the Russia hoax
Russia Russia Russia remember whatever
happened to that one I think when Trump
talks to the crowd about John Durham
they think he's talking about Bull
Durham which is something different
altogether and then he goes Ukraine
Ukraine Ukraine that turned out to be
another hoax remember that
he had a terrible call I will tell you
you know
the president of Ukraine they asked him
about it they said the president he said
the president did nothing wrong and I
knew he said he didn't do anything wrong
wasn't it great that we had to call
essentially taped wasn't that wonderful
Mr President did they die when they
heard we had the coil taped
I would have had a problem because these
people are horrible liar Shifty shift
kids why hasn't the audio been released
then for a country
I called to congratulate him on a
victory I never met the gentleman but
you know what he's standing up tall now
and I liked him then because he had
courage and he said we did nothing wrong
I think they thought that these people
were crazy actually
on a similar basis massive conspiracy to
hide the truth about Joe and Hunter
Biden's corruption is
being fully exposed and with your vote
this November the rig system really can
come down to a crashing halt got to stop
it they're going to vote to change the
rigged voting system wait so wouldn't
those who rigged it just make your vote
not count like I I don't you know the
environmental alarmists everything the
country is going to be gone we have a
guy threatening nuclear weapons every
day in Russia and they're talking about
in 300 years our ocean is going to be
one one hundredth of an inch higher
300 years from now
we have to immediately clean up our
factories because
we don't have to clean up our air what
they don't say is that Chinese there the
China China Air is so dirty oh my God
Russia air is so dirty India is so dirty
Japan he does seem High I mean this is
making no sense because
it goes and it blows
United States okay what are they gonna
do
it but none of this will matter if we
don't do one thing restore Integrity to
our elections
has to do it
at the federal state and local level
Republicans must act to ensure Universal
voter ID
you know it's interesting in the
Democrat convention they had it in
Milwaukee and I saw people no walking
they had signs like posters on their
chest
with their picture all sorts of
identification but they don't want that
to vote the only reason they don't want
voter ID is because they're cheaters
they cheat there's no other reason
it's like a 94 issue even in the
Democrats the Democrats want voter ID
the only one that doesn't are the
Democrat politicians to see I happen to
think that
bad oil and high prices and if you look
at people that are against the Second
Amendment you can't have guns to protect
yourself against God against so much
Sanctuary cities they want Sanctuary
cities
they want high taxes they want to they
want to double and triple your taxes I
happen to think that they don't really
have a 50 50 party with the Republicans
does Trump know like you can't make
taxes more than a hundred percent
because there's no way you go to Texas
they're against God against guns and
against oil
and then I hear oh it's going to be
close well actually we want a landslide
okay but you know they say it's going to
be close you know why they said it's
going to be close because if they can
find enough votes millions of votes if
they can find it the people won't be so
shocked if they can pull it out now I
just think that uh we have to clean it
up and I think Ted Budd is going to do a
lot in that regard I think it's one of
his big issues yeah because if we don't
have clean elections and if we don't
have strong borders we do not have a
country we don't have a country we also
have to look at citizenship confirmation
no more drop boxes the fake drop boxes
afternoon
one hundred percent of the votes to
Biden and nothing to Trump yeah I didn't
do too well with that particular
private money pouring into local
election offices organized by
billionaires CEOs I wonder who we're
talking about and we must ensure that
every election can be fully and quickly
audited and you have to look at the
movie that's coming out this week Dinesh
D'Souza the new Batman they have
everything thing on tape they have a big
portion of what went on on tape there
are many different things they cheated
on many different levels in many
different ways right but look at this
and Dinesh d'souzas the guy with the
inside info on it and they have it on
PING they have it all over the place
it's pallet harvesting at a level that
nobody ever thought possible anybody
know what Ping is and another one
citizens united David bossi I just saw
that one and that is brutal in terms of
cheating in terms of people pouring you
know if you spend more than five
thousand six hundred dollars on an
election they put you in jail they're
very strict yeah we know five thousand
six hundred dollars this guy Zuckerberg
spent 417 million dollars
[Music]
yeah Dinesh D'Souza knowingly went
around campaign Finance law by giving
other people money to donate as a proxy
like that it's just a crime it's against
the law change the law if you don't like
it but it's a crime now here's the bad
news the fake news won't even report it
they won't report it they won't report
it they won't talk about it well Sean
Spicer's face looks really small not his
head just his face now a lower approval
rating than Congress can you believe
that
a lorry approval rating then
then did you well these guys this Cooper
Congressman they're way up there they're
so you're so far up the ultimate goal
would be
same-day elections using paper ballots
with mail-in ballots only the military
can use mail-in ballots or those who are
very sick or ill
and who can't vote in person so if
you're very sick
and you can't vote good and if you're in
the military you're in a far away place
or Port good and that's it and wouldn't
it be nice to have same day like we do
we could do that easily same-day
elections so that you go like we used to
have you know when elections were much
more honest
instead of sitting around for 48 days we
have boxes stored in that storage room
oh really who's store who's watching it
why is it a lock on the door
why is people putting things in and out
now we need same day and we need paper
ballots
we could have honest elections so easily
when California sends out tens of
millions of mail-in ballots nobody knows
where the hell they're going who's
getting them and how many people here
have had friends who received more than
one ballot nobody yeah
I know so many people can you imagine
half the people behind him raising their
hands that is that is
[ __ ] it's higher than that from what
I understand we're just seven months
away from the most important midterm
victory in American history and we need
a landslide so big that the radical left
cannot rig it or steal it ah okay
so that's the explanation
by the way I endorsed another person
today Dr Oz in Pennsylvania Dr Oz wow
great guy a good man what an endorsement
Harvard educated tremendous tremendous
career and they liked him for I thought
Harvard was bad have you guys noticed
how if one of their people went to
Harvard Harvard's great oh Ted Cruz went
to Harvard he's a legal scholar oh my
God Harvard Harvard is woke Harvard's BS
it's liberal indoctrination back America
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back our beautiful
beautiful beautiful White House
right
all right try again
I like those people behind me I don't
know who the hell they are
you know I always say
those people may have lousy seats and
you may have great seats but they're
going to be much more famous than you
are tomorrow
they'll be called in some of them will
be called in because they're so
attractive they'll be called into
Hollywood tomorrow
with the Republican Congress we will
fight for more jobs for North Carolina
families fair trade for North Carolina
workers and more North Carolina
factories forging more products was
stamped and you know what that beautiful
phrase is made in the USA we're using it
more and more
we will shut down Joe Biden's border
disaster Institute remain in Mexico
reimposed title 42 strengthen ice these
are great Heroes and border patrol those
are great Heroes they're courageous
people you know they go into these nests
you know the nest is Sheriff you know
what in this is another animal term
and it's MS-13 these are tough people
they like knives because they like
cutting people instead of shooting
people because it's more painful and it
takes longer Sheriff knows and it's a
horrible thing and these ice people I
tell you I know a couple of people in
the front are you really tough you don't
want this job they go into a nest they
run into a nest and they start fighting
it out and then they grab them and they
throw them they bring them back to their
country and their countries didn't take
them under Obama and uh so we were stuck
mom and I heard that my first week they
said sir we can't bring them back to
Guatemala we can't bring them back to us
Mr President Mr President
I don't know
sir we give them
778 million dollars a year I said call
them and tell them we're not paying them
anymore until they take the people back
and then the next day Sheriff I got a
call from the three presidents
separately
sir why aren't you paying us the money
because you won't take them back but sir
we'd love to take back MS-13 different
people
we would love to take them back and we
had no problem after that you know
we still haven't paid them by the way
you know it's very interesting we know
and Biden just announced that instead of
778 million dollars they want to pay 4
billion dollars to these countries 4
billion you know who's going to get that
the drug lords
the politicians a lot of people are
going to get that sheriff no good but we
got them all back we got them thousand I
just want to take a lot of we got to
give them a great hand to ice to border
patrol and to law enforcement
[Applause]
that I didn't know she was here
she comes from a slightly warmer climate
foreign
Lake she's going to be the next governor
of Arizona so nice that you're here I
didn't know you were here Carrie
wow they all love Carrie everyone knows
she's a lunatic
Carrie's got a massive lead in Arizona
she was their anchor for 22 years in
Arizona and she saw the way things were
running and she wasn't happy they have a
lousy governor in Arizona really allows
happens to be Republican he's still
lousy they wanted him to run for the
Senate I said well I'll never endorse
him I can tell you so he took a pass
but uh Carey lake is fantastic and I
heard you pull numbers through the roof
I think they're kind of kind of like Ted
Bud's Paul numbers they're quite up
there right so let's have a contest who
does better you or Ted Bud there you go
but Carrie lake has done fantastically
she's going to be a great governor we
will again end Catch and Release we will
end chain migrate is the teleprompter
repeating because he said he's gonna end
Catch and Release three or four times x
finished the wall it takes three weeks
to finish it
we will stop the Biden crime wave in
democrat-run cities we will give our
police we love our police their power
back
and let them do what they do better than
anybody else
and we're going to give them also
something else we're going to give the
police their respect back
and we will restore Law and Order again
in America
we will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus throughout the
world we will create a military so
powerful I've sort of already done this
that no one don't forget two and a half
trillion and you know we have a nuclear
force that I rebuilt along with the
military and I hate even talking about
it right but we have the most powerful
nuclear force we had weapons that were
48 years old nobody even knew of their
work we've refurbished and rebuilt and
brand new in many cases are nuclear
capability so
we don't like talking about it and
honestly Putin shouldn't be talking
about it shouldn't be talking about it
and if they do talk about it we have to
have somebody that knows how to talk
back not to say oh there are nuclear
force
we will lead Humanity back to the Moon
and the United States will be the first
nation to land an astronaut on Mars
that's happening very quickly Nars
protect innocent life we will defend our
constitution we will defend the Second
Amendment and we will proudly uphold the
judeo-christian values and principles of
our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American this the cadences that he's
already winding down he's only been
speaking 61 minutes which I would love I
would love for him to rap already
[Applause]
and we will not by the way
have men participating in women's sports
[Applause]
and we will ban men
did you see the swimming record it was
up for 11 years and
a great young
woman no no there's a great young woman
she's been working so hard and she
thought she could beat it by 1 8 of one
second
and then this guy comes along and beats
it by 38 seconds
didn't Leah Thomas lose some other races
too I mean like I you know I've I think
it's a complicated issue but it's not
like Leah Thomas won every race even
and then this guy comes along
and he never lifted weights before right
no way that's so good that's so
ridiculous I mean and you know people
are afraid to talk I'm talk about it
because I talk about it I talk common
sense
people you have to talk about it
you know even the teammates they don't
want to do it they think it's
Politically Incorrect to talk about it
there's nothing Politically Incorrect
it's going to destroy women's sports
[Applause]
I mean if I'm a basketball coach I
guarantee I'm going to have a great team
but you know why because I'm not going
to say it because that would be
Politically Incorrect and say isn't that
terrible you can't let this happen you
can't let it happen to women sports it's
very unfair to women don't let it happen
hey why is Trump's right eye almost
completely shut anybody know
in conclusion our Maga movement is by
far the greatest political movement in
the history of our country
and nobody can say otherwise even the
fake news can't say anything differently
together we are standing up against some
of the most Sinister forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people have ever witnessed or seen
but no matter how big or powerful these
corrupt radicals may be
you must in conclusion has real third
grade book report Vibes that belong to
them this nation belongs to you
this is your home this is your heritage
and our American Liberty is your
god-given right this state this is a
great state was forged by some of the
toughest men and some of the strongest
women ever to walk the face of the Earth
our American ancestors were Backcountry
farmers woodsmen and craftsmen who
poured their love into this land with
their families and all of their friends
credible what they've done and they were
bold pioneers and Frontier settlers who
climbed the mountains tamed the
Wilderness and kept on pushing West West
and above all they were proud citizens
fiercely independent North Carolina men
and women who Blaze their own trail and
took orders from nobody
it was hard-working Patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working Patriots like you who are
going to save our country
we're not going to let our country
be destroyed by lunatics
we are going to fight for America like
no one has ever fought before we will
not let radical left people that don't
love our country or rhinos we have bad
rhinos too we have some sick sick stupid
weak people take away from us what has
been so brilliantly forged over nearly
250 years there is no mountain we cannot
climb there is no Summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet you
can tell Trump's deeply spiritual f we
will not Bend we will not break we will
not yield we will never give in we will
never give up we will never ever ever
ever back down North Carolina
as long as we are confident and United
the tyrants we are fighting do not stand
even a little chance because we are
Americans and Americans kneel to God and
God Alone
my fellow that's a dog whistle the
Kaepernick right Bernie we are on
together has only just begun and it is
time to start talking about greatness
for our country again greatness we don't
talk about greatness anymore you never
hear the word greatness
we talk about
the environment and we all want a clean
environment we talk about race and we
want great race relations we talk about
many other things but we never talk
about greatness for our country we want
to make our country great again right
now our countries are laughingstock all
over the world
they don't even return the phone calls
of our president never been in a
position like this our country you can
say a lot of things about Biden but our
relationships with world leaders and
historical allies have improved
dramatically since Trump left people one
family and one glorious American Nation
and so with the help of everyone here
today and citizens all across our land
we will make America powerful again
we will make America wealthy again we
will make America strong again we will
make America proud again
we will make America safe again
and we will make America great again
thank you North Carolina thank you God
bless you God bless you
yeah
so uh Trump's speaking for one hour and
seven minutes
folks former president definitely on the
short end for sure
and a very welcome when if when Trump
can keep it under 70 minutes
I'm pretty pleased
uh it's it's it's a good thing it's a
good thing thanks to Hoosier DZ for the
twitch Prime subscription thank you to
everyone who has gifted so many
memberships As Trump continues to dance
here
the dancing has gotten weirder and
weirder I have to say
yeah wow
[Music]
uh what a what a wild situation what a
wild situation I hope that you guys are
going to join our town hall
we have a town hall scheduled for April
19th at 6 PM Eastern it will be
streaming live only on the Pac-Man Live
YouTube channel wow this guy
we will be hearing from so many of you
and it's gonna be great
Trump uh making his way down the stairs
[Music]
these are really weird events
[Music]
yeah they have real Jim Jones vibes
[Music]
in all seriousness two really great
books about cults
are Jeff Gwynn's book about
the people's temple with Jim Jim Jones
and his book about uh Charles Manson uh
the family
really incredibly well researched books
just it really reading them has informed
me
about the Trump cult in so many ways
because there are so so many
similarities
and uh Scientology yeah I know less
about scientology in this particular
sense
um but there goes Trump another
very weird event a lot of coughing going
on among the people on the stage there
and a big event for Ted Budd Ted bud so
now the attendees will have hours of
trying to get out it's very hard to
leave a trump rally I am sure the
sanicans are quite fetid at this point
as we determined earlier
uh but that is it that is it I will be
back this week with shows from the
studio from the studio back from the
trip
and I am so glad that all of you joined
me today we have a beautiful twitch
subscriber number of seven seven
just an absolutely perfect number and
remember you can buy a pillow from Mike
pillow with a coupon code
or you can get a membership from me with
a coupon code
it's your choice which you want to do I
will leave you everybody with that
thought today uh and we will see
everybody very soon Monday for me